more exciting than breakfast and a lot
more enjoyable to cook brunch is ideal
for sharing
first up my simple and delicious
frittata
eggs are great they are so versatile and
once you've mastered how to cook them
trust me the door then opens to a wide
range of delicious options
this is like a triple omelette but a lot
more ingredients than a normal mesh
we'll start off with some lovely smoked
bacon slice
the bacon bacon in
those salts
little touch of pepper
start off on a high heat get that bacon
really nice and crispy
otherwise you just boil the bacon and
it's got that soft unpleasant texture in
the frittata
turn down the gas and now start adding
your veg
roughly chop a red pepper and add it to
the pan
the peppers on the bacon take the
longest so they've always got to go in
first
now soaking them off
the peppers have been cooked now from
that sort of rendered fat from the bacon
and then
the spring onions
just bunch them up
slice them i want them on an angle
so they come like little green diamonds
spring onions in
now
for the eggs
cracking the eggs
for that size pan
seven or eight eggs
i want to fill it right to the very top
and more importantly when i
turn this out
i want it like a gato nice and thick so
slice through and see all those
wonderful verge
[Music]
i'm gonna season the eggs
with some parmesan cheese be quite
generous because it adds a really nice
saltiness
[Music]
fresh ground pepper and then whisk
whisk up those eggs nicely
[Music]
then add peas to the pan
and to give the dish a wonderful
aromatic freshness some fragrant chopped
basil
i want to chop that sort of roughly
because i want to see those flecks of
green going in
i want it looking charming and how many
times have you seen a
dull omelet
frittatas in my mind really helped
encapsulate the magic of having
savoury eggs
cooked beautifully
but with texture
now just before we add the eggs
i've got this
beautiful little goat's cheese and it's
strong and powerful
so i want to slice it
into little chunks
and then just
have it
dotted around i want to discover these
little pockets of creamy goat's cheese
now slowly
add the eggs
[Music]
fill that right up
and get your spoon
now just let all that egg go down to the
bottom
bring it back up to the boil
and sort of clean
around the sides and then some of this
delicious
salty
creamy goat's cheese over the top
now
i want it melting like a
a perfect slice
of cheese on toast
nice
now
from there turn the grill on for four to
five minutes
[Music]
now
just looking at that
delicious
take a little paring knife and just
make sure
it's released
on the sides just take your panel
tap
that will hopefully release the frittata
from the bottom of the pan
now
the board over the pan
turn that
gently
and just
shake
say a little prayer
and lift off
beautiful
[Music]
now
from
there on
there it's there look
now
slice
through
you can see
how soft and creamy that is in the
center and that goat's cheese is just
melting almost like a little sauce
inside it's so exciting but more
importantly it's so easy to do
it's got texture it's got creaminess and
that for me will beat any omelette for
brunch serve with a stack of hot butter
toast and a steaming pot of coffee this
easy frittata turned the humble egg into
the perfect dish for kicking off the
weekend
[Music]
brunch should be a laid-back affair and
a treat so the dishes need to be easy to
cook but never boring
my next recipe takes the humble pancake
to a whole new level of flavour and
excitement
soft fiery and irresistible
spicy pancakes
one of the secrets to good cooking is
learning to use your imagination when it
comes to brunches you don't have to
stick to the old standbys these
delicious spicy pancakes are really
great alternative but more importantly
so easy to do
start off by toasting your cumin
[Music]
it's a dry roast basically non-stick pan
just a touch of seasoning
the salt helps to dry out the cumin even
more
and then fresh ginger slice them nice
and thinly
stack it back up
and then just slice nice little thin
slices in there
and then keep that bunched up
shake the chilli
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot
now
garlic
nice now
add olive oil to your toasted cumin
seeds and then with the garlic ginger
and chili lovely
[Music]
and it feels strange when you talk about
garlic for breakfast but the time i
spent in india
everybody was eating something savory
for breakfast it was extraordinary
into your bowl
and set aside
next the pancake filling add olive oil
to a hot pan
mustard seeds in now they'll start
dancing the minute they hit the pan
then finely slice an onion
onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in
and look at the color
an instant change
leftover potatoes
just slice them
the smell is incredible potatoes in now
spread the potatoes across the pan while
the potatoes stained i want them sort of
absorbing all that really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge
season those potatoes and it really
helps to bring out
the spice beautifully
they're ready
turn off the gas and let them sit there
and absorb all those flavors
back to the pancake batter add plain
flour to your cooled garlic chili ginger
and cumin seeds
touch
salt and pepper nothing worse than the
bland pancake
one whole egg
milk
hold the jug with one hand and whisk we
have a secret to get that really nice
smooth paste
but
whisk in that egg first and brings it
together
and then you're milking
don't put all the milk in because then
you're gonna get a lumpy pancake mix
and if you put less milk in
it really helps it
not going lumpy
look at that
milk here
and the secret for me is to have a nice
thin mix
now just
a little teaspoon
of oil that helps to bring
a nice crispy edge to the mixture
now just taste it
that's the texture pan on the larger the
pan the better it helps to create a nice
thin even surface i want that mix going
all the way around the pan before you
put the mixture into the pan make sure
you give your pancake mix a really nice
stir
pan it's nice and hot
turn down the gas
a touch of olive oil in get that nice
whisk with one hand
pan to the mix
in
one and a half ladles
and then roll it around so it's really
nice and thin i want to see the ginger
the garlic that's what i'm looking for
in there now back onto the heat it only
starts to remove from the bottom of the
pan and lifts itself up once it's cooked
these little bubbles
confirm that it's just starting to lift
off
the pan
a little shake that releases it
and then just shake it to the end
and toss
if you haven't got the confidence
tossing then use a spatula and turn it
over now
that's exactly what i want that nice
sort of crisp edge around the side the
colour on the pancake is so important
now
roll it round
and just let it slide out
beautifully
now
for the exciting part filling them
take your potatoes
just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line
and then just very carefully
roll that
nice
and tightly tuck it underneath there
pull it back
and roll
usually
the delicious pancakes are ready to eat
but with a simple dipping sauce there'll
be a real treat just mix chopped
coriander with natural yogurt
that's really nice cooling asian sit
there on the side
and that for me is a great brunch
delicious spicy pancakes amazing
[Music]
and one of my all-time favorites a dish
that always creates a stir is the daddy
of all brunches
steak sandwiches
[Music]
for me the secret of a great brunch is
fun and casual fuss-free cooking and
everyone helping themselves
this is the ultimate steak sandwich
you want the rolls royce of beef
it has to be fill it
now season it beautifully
i like to open up
the top of the peppermill to increase
the size of the pepper in the steak so
it gives that bit of heat
nice little chunks
you just roll now
nicely all the way around
now slice the garlic
in half
pan nice and hot
olive oil in
hold the steak and just place it into
the pan don't drop it
at the front of the pan
we're going to tilt the pan forward to
cook the back of the steak dual purpose
now roll it
back and sear underneath
next
my garlic
and roast that garlic
thyme
fry that time i want to hear it we're
not looking for a lot of color because
you're going to dry out the fill it
so
just
one end
turn it back down
and stir the other end in
lift up your time place it on top of the
garlic
there
lift up your fillet
and sit there on
top
of your garlic
butter in
take a spoon
tilt the pan gently
lift up
and baste
i've got that scented garlic
thyme flavor
the steak is going to cook evenly
because it's sat on a little
a little bed
in the oven for eight to ten minutes
[Music]
pan on
for the relish you think of a steak
sandwich you think of a sort of nice
heated tomato relish
to make the relish finely dice a red
onion three finger rule one in front
two behind
through
and chop
wow
next roughly chop a chilli keeping the
seeds in for extra heat start off with
the olive oil
into a pan
onions
chilies
[Music]
generous with the olive oil
i want a nice sort of rich
silky
relish
from there
take your tomatoes you can't just use
red tomatoes but these
yellow and red make the perfect
combination
now put your salt in
pepper
and then
roast those tomatoes off
take a wooden spoon and just sort of
break them up
once the skins blister
the whole tomato just starts to release
all that really nice sweet texture
a little teaspoon of cherry vinegar
gives that nice acidic balance the
sweetness of the tomatoes turn down the
gas and just let them sort of stew
perfectly
now a steak sandwich would not be
complete unless it had the most amazing
mustard mayonnaise
simply add three tablespoons of
mayonnaise to three teaspoons of whole
grain mustard
[Music]
now i've got the reddish almost down to
like a really nice jam
now
i wanna make that relish a little bit
more fragrant
some basil
slice it through
sprinkle that basil in there
[Music]
beautiful
look at this
there she is
my crown jewels
time to take it out
smell is incredible
just based one more time
to fill it
touch is quite soft in the center so
it's just coming up to mid-rare let it
rest at the same time you cooked it
it'll be nice and pink evenly throughout
the steak
to make my sandwich i'm going to char
grill some sliced chipatta bread season
it nicely
just a little drizzle of olive oil i
want to get that bread nice and crispy
pan nice and hot
bread
in
push it down
smell is amazing that char sort of
charcoal flavour once you've got those
marks on the bread it just stops the
bread from becoming soggy and look at
this here
it is
stunning
on
slice it
gently
one beautiful slice
wow
it's nice and pink all the way through
and the beef is so soft
it's almost like slicing through butter
let the knife do the work
take
a little bit of mayonnaise spread that
the back of the spoon
on both sides
next
lettuce
take that beautiful slice of beef
and then relish
on top of that beef and just slice the
sandwich in half
beautiful
now that's what i call a steak sandwich
trust me serve the sublime sandwich for
brunch and you'll put a smile on
everyone's face
you